1-1
pretty well hit in the center field
driving back taylor oversight
roduko has started downing a bunch of
games lately by getting on base he rips
a double yeah taylor did not get a good
jump on that ball
that ball fooled him i thought he stung
it too i could i was surprised he wasn't
on his horse slices it just a hair but
he stung it look at it he starts in he
goes sideways and then goes back on it
and that's why that ball beat him just
out of his reach
way out of his reach double easy there
for verdugo
so that leaves it to xander bogarts to
pick up the rbi looking for his 42nd
and a 1-2 from keller oh how about that
he poked it in his center field and he
drove in a run
sweet as you please didn't crush it but
the red sox leaded one to nothing he
picks up rbi number 42.
good breaking ball biting down and away
little pokes
one hand poke job that is a beautiful
rbi
base hit
it's ugly or beautiful depends on what
side you're on the pit on the field
by the way that was whitt's first
leadoff walk since
may 22nd almost a month ago
and whit goes on the first pitch throw
by vasquez
safe
oh man great take off that's the 18th
bag
actually he's 18 for 18. ever since the
first
steal of the year he got caught look at
that he's able to get under that one hop
throw there
from vasquez but you steal off the
pitcher
and he picked a great pitch to go on it
was an off speed pitch
whit goes the pitch is swung on and
missed and merefield
will steal third base without a throw he
has an idea look at him having straight
in the baseline right there he goes
directly to the bag when you're stealing
bases you don't want to be behind second
base you want to be even with the bag
just like he is there
and he had several pitches to measure
him up
everybody in tight here comes the o2
pitch
a little roller runner trying to score
the throw home off contact he tried to
score he's out
sander bogart is cutting him down the
tag by vasquez
nicely done in field in ground ball you
can't take your time you got to hurry up
with that throw but an easy play there
he tags him on the chest but he's at
third base there on that steal
that was a big steal i thought there was
two outs that's why i said something
like you can have third base all day
long
luckily you didn't really mean it i
didn't really mean it i said wait a
minute
you can't have third base
there's a blooper towards right and
that's going to drop for a hit go for
two
down again he's putting the brakes on
renfrow's got a very good arm i like it
that's how you play the game
because it helps grow our game went to
right field lopez turned second
the throw hits lopez in the head then
bounces away
with goes hard around second he gets
back
in time just barely and so whit was
coming to third he had to put the brakes
on seeing that nikki didn't go home
but look at that hitting that's
beautiful he chokes up on the bat he
goes to the opposite field
he's able to feather that right past the
second baseman who is diving in the
royals
with some key hit a key hit right there
from whit but nobody out have second and
third a chance to get on the board
they'll play the infield back they'll
give up a run to get it out
two-third they look home throw to first
lopez scores to tie the game and
santana did his job wit stays at second
whit goes pitch taken and that's the
third steal for merrifield
so why even risk throwing the ball away
you got a right-handed batter in the box
you got to throw around him there's no
need to force that
lead off walk to [ __ ] hernandez he's
running
and that one is stroked to left field
hit pretty well dozier back over his
head
takes a bounce away from him here comes
kiki he was in motion anyway
he's gonna trot in dolbeck on his way
into third
the throw is not gonna get him and the
red sox are on the board again
bobby d strikes for second time today
his second knock
luckily this ball stays in the ballpark
for keller that ball was scalded
maybe a little topspin that ball is over
his head in a heartbeat
and kicks away [ __ ] scores easy and you
see dog back all the way to third
and a roll over on this one that'll get
it done
and be tagged out as the run comes in to
score so
danny santana brings in the run well
that is the ultimate huh make a little
contact
barely make contact on the day gd is
grounded to short he's lined out to
right
over two and sacks have capitalized on
one walk by keller in the inning
to get kiki hernandez in oh
drive out to left field this one deep
and yes sir
kiss it goodbye his 100th home run with
the boston red sox
little spinner i mean that that's
supposed to be a cross seamer didn't
have a lot on it left it on the inner
half and he lost it
loved that sound ball bridge 5-1 red sox
now to left center field and taylor lays
out again
you know what this is really what you
have a center fielder
this that's an athlete that's what he's
there for he's got
great ability to read the ball off the
bat
pick up the spin rodrigo says oh come on
man
in the air right side long run for
merrifield will he get there
yes he will how about the outfield
defense
two plays by michael a taylor and this
one by whitmerfield
merrifield is everywhere
all over look at him he's calling it
he's had
some kind of afternoon way to pick up
koara
one man out one man on red sox five
kansas city one
ninth inning he'll go the other way a
high fly that's deep backing on
murrayfield turning down
he saw one before waited back and drove
it it's kind of power this kid's got
he didn't really get it all he didn't he
didn't but got enough of it